Sherrell Dorsey: Melonie, I'm so honored
to be sitting and sharing
the stage with you.
Melonie D. Parker: I couldn't wait
for today to have our conversation
joined with all these lovely women.
SD: There's so much to cover.
To be at this experience,
to be celebrating the power,
the voice, the ideas of women.
There's also some really grappling
and gripping conversations
that we have to have,
particularly around diversity,
this idea of equity, as well as inclusion.
And your work, even beyond your title,
has been extremely massive.
But we also have to look
at what the last few years has entailed
and what commitments have been
made from corporate entities.
And so I want to dive in today,
with you this morning,
about where we sort of were
and where we're going.
But maybe let's start
with this commitment,
particularly that Google made
right out of the gate,
particularly when we think about 2020,
the murder of George Floyd
and the sort of subsequent
reckonings that our country,
that the world has had
and what that's meant for your team,
for your organization at large,
and how we're starting to think
a little bit differently
about the shifts that are now happening.
MDP: So it's a great question.
And even before we get to like,
the horrific murder of George Floyd,
I think we need to step back
a little bit further
and think about COVID
and the comorbidities
that were exacerbated.
You know, we thought
about who was killed by COVID.
And I think that brought
a spotlight that exacerbated
when we started to look
at police brutality
and, you know, before George Floyd,
there was Breonna Taylor, Ahmaud Arbery.
And this wasn't like an episodic event.
It really led to a global
racial equity movement.
And I think global here is important.
So I have four generations
in my household.
My mom's 85,
the youngest in my household,
I'm a new Gigi to a granddaughter,
and my mom said --
who marched in the 1960s
with Dr Martin Luther King,
both of my parents did, she said,
"I can't believe that people
outside of the United States
care about police brutality
towards Black Americans."
I mean, she was stunned by this.
And so I think that backdrop is important.
So what we did at Google,
like, quickly recognizing,
hey, this isn't a series
of episodic events, this is a movement.
And we need to immediately deepen
the work that we're doing.
So we went on a 100-day sprint
as a company, not just my team,
which is a very representative team,
I have a rock-star team
that enables everything that I do.
But this was a company.
So we did a call to action
globally, across Google,
and our goal was to really ensure
that we were building sustainable equity
internally and externally.
And so we had teams that looked
at all of our products
and how do we use our products
for social good,
which is embedded
in the mission of Google,
to ensure that our products
are helpful and accessible.
And then internally looking at --
we used our Black leadership,
our Black executives
and our Black Googler Network,
which is our employee resource group,
to look at what do we need to do
internally to build equity
and not just across the Black community,
but across underrepresented minority.
So we look at Black, Latinx,
Hispanic population
as well as Indigenous community.
Out of that, we had eight commitments:
four external, four internal.
We've invested over 500 million dollars
in the racial equity commitments.
And they complete in 2025.
So we've learned a lot along the way.
And we do this work as a collective
with civil rights organizations,
human rights organizations, you know,
other organizations,
because you can't do
this work in isolation.
This work, we have to go together.
SD: What's been really -- first of all,
that's really fascinating.
And thank you for really
spelling that out for us.
What's really interesting is,
there is almost this new identity around
what discrimination, what marginalization
and even racism, if we can just call it
by the the term that it is,
has inflicted on various groups.
And it is sometimes a challenge to think
that it took a series
of very catastrophic events,
including a tremendous
public health crisis,
to get to a place where
our ears were open, right?
And even when I think about the nature
of the partnerships that you all have had,
particularly when it comes to HBCUs,
which you are an alum.
MDP: Proud Hampton University alum.
SD: Any HBCUs?
I heard there are some HBCU students.
MDP: I love all HBCUs,
but particular to ...
SD: So I'm not part of the club
because I did not attend an HBCU.
But I hope one day to be an honorary
member of Spelman.
I should have been a Spelman woman.
(Cheers)
Alright, I see, OK.
MDP: I'm sure Dr Gayle
is beaming right now.
Love to have you at Spelman.
SD: I just need a sweatshirt.
So meet me after, meet me after.
But there are some unique
partnerships that are expanding
beyond just social justice initiatives
and even stepping
into an area of education.
And very unique partnerships,
particularly around the future of work,
which, when we think about inequalities,
when we talk about the racial wealth gap,
when we talk about who gets
to build the future,
who gets to imagine a future,
a lot of times when we think
about the folks who are left out,
that is women, that is other
marginalized folks of color
who don't necessarily get access
in the same way
that some of our counterparts do.
And there's a particular emphasis
on unique partnerships,
in order to create, upskill, reskill,
or even teach particular skill sets
that are going to be found in the future.
Can you speak to that a little bit more?
MDP: Yes, and so it's an incredible
observation and insight.
You know, let's start
with our historically Black colleges
and universities,
which are national treasures.
And we have to surround our HBCUs
and ensure that we continue the pipeline.
And part of that, yes,
is investing in the pipeline
for development to make sure
that we're hiring.
But there's a bigger part to this picture.
And so at Google, I lead
an HBCU President's Council.
And one of the things we're doing,
in addition to creating opportunities
for internships and hiring,
is we are helping to amplify
research opportunities.
And so, I'm not sure
if you know this, Sherrell,
but out of the HBCU landscape,
there are no HBCUs currently
that are at R1 research standing,
and that means that we have
a stewardship responsibility
to ensure that we're providing
research opportunities,
but research opportunities also not --
They don't just provide development,
they also provide diverse voices,
diverse ideas, diverse thoughts
into cutting-edge research.
But we just launched
an applied research institute
a couple of weeks ago,
in partnership with UNCF and TMCF,
focused on HBCUs with mathematical
and computational research
to provide these hands-on opportunities.
And with Spelman College
through Google.org,
we provided a five million-dollar grant
for a women of color STEAM database.
No one else is doing this.
And so Google developers,
other HBCUs are partnering
hand in hand with Spelman
to create this database.
And this is the type of opportunity
that we have to continue to provide.
And just, you know, one other example,
at Howard University,
we have a partnership
that we just announced.
It's called Project Elevate Black Voices.
So how many of you are familiar
with automatic speech technology?
And I don't know about you,
sometimes I use it
and it doesn't recognize my voice.
And so Google's research,
as well as external research,
you know, has determined and validated
that it doesn't universally
recognize all voices.
So Howard University
holds the licensing rights,
but they are doing that research
to improve the technology.
These are the types of opportunities
and unique partnerships
that we have to have
to not only build the pipeline,
but to ensure that we have
diversity in the design,
in the products and in the services.
SD: That's super incredible,
particularly for students
who are currently at these institutions
and are going to get access
and opportunity.
I think also to Google executives
and employees as well,
who provide mentorship
and leadership as well
amongst these particular programs.
And you talked about the partnerships
with the United Negro College Fund,
the Thurgood Marshall Foundation,
and oddly enough, in 2020 --
And I always want to go back to that date
because there were some
really interesting realities.
People, for the first time,
we're learning about all of these
organizations that were supporting
and have been doing work for decades.
So for a lot of folks,
that was kind of a first-hand discovery.
So when I think about this area
of DE and I and sort of 2020 to 2021,
we saw sort of the largest growth
of chief diversity officers being named
for the first time in corporate spaces.
We saw this kind of deluge of focus
on things like a 15-percent pledge
across retail or representation on stages
or even within authorship and books.
And then we hit 2022.
And we saw this sort of decline
economically, of course,
housing to inflation
to all of these things
that started to take precedence,
which also meant the pullback
of all of those big promises,
those hyper focuses.
And the shift was very palpable
for so many of us.
And we kind of knew
that it was going to come.
We knew that the focus and the language
and almost the hysteria around
how do we elevate marginalized voices
might take a turn.
So we sort of had to think about,
OK, if we're going to have this spotlight
for like, 12 to 18 months,
like, how do we, like,
rush out and get it done?
What's fascinating is you talk
about these pillars,
these eight pillars and these goals
that are going to be accomplished by 2025,
which is absolutely fascinating.
And so I want to get an understanding of
why has this work stayed the course,
and where are we going.
Because I hear these amazing
initiatives and opportunities.
I hear of the dedication.
You're one of the few remaining
chief diversity officers, unfortunately,
that's really heading a major company.
But I think that many of us might be
concerned about, is this a fad,
are we going to have to
change language now?
We're only talking about ESG now?
We're only talking about terms
in a certain kind of way,
because now all of the language we learned
in the last two years
is somehow deemed offensive?
So maybe you can paint a picture
of hope in some cases.
MDP: I was just thinking that.
So let me let me interject with some hope.
So what we're seeing today,
I don't lose heart.
I do have hope.
I mean, my parents, I told you,
marched in the 1960s
with Dr Martin Luther King.
And so we've seen this in history before.
One of the things that we've normalized
that we're not going to go back from,
we talk openly about race
in the workplace.
I mean, if you think about,
particularly Black and Brown communities
are either hyper visible or invisible.
In between that,
it's a whole lot of stress.
And so what we're talking about
is how do we normalize Black
and Brown communities in the context?
And that's what we've done
following the murder of George Floyd.
I think that's also why
we've seen some of the pushback.
But we're not going to go back
to where we [were].
I have a lot of hope with Gen X,
the way that, you know,
they have forced a demand
for how we interact,
what they want, how they show up.
And we're really leaning into that.
And so I want to make sure
that we don't operate out of fear
and that we don't retract,
that we stand strong.
And Google is standing strong
and unapologetic
about the commitment we make.
And we're able to do that.
And I'm able to sit in my role
because we have an incredible CEO
with Sundar Pichai
who really gets it, understands it,
and it's a company imperative.
So we have racial equity goals,
but we also have company-wide
goals as well.
And our CEO meets with our HBCU
Presidents Council as well
and spends and pours time there.
And so these are the types
of things that we have to hold on to.
But they're also the things
that we have to push for
and to continue to demand fairness
and respect and dignity,
which go hand in hand with equity
and diversity and inclusion.
And there's a lot of talk
now about belonging.
And I think we should hit this head on.
I believe that diversity,
equity and inclusion
is insufficient without belonging.
Like, insufficient without
recognizing that everybody --
The science of belonging says
that people have to feel rewarded, seen,
recognized and valued
in order to feel like they belong.
And so I think we see this added on.
And so these are the types
of competencies and capabilities
that are here to stay,
even though we get pushback.
But pushback means
there's progress happening
and the research shows
that there's progress happening.
SD: A little discomfort is good
for all of us, right?
A little discomfort is good for the soul.
Anybody been uncomfortable? Yeah.
Alright, major growth spurts
happening around here.
I love how you talk about,
or you brought in
that concept of belonging.
And also highlighted the different
requirements of generations.
I think, you know, I'm considered
a geriatric millennial.
Is anyone else here
a geriatric millennial?
(Scattered applause)
Yes! Shout out, yes.
MDP: I'm Gen X, so where are
my Gen X people? (Laughs)
(Scattered applause)
SD: Kids of the '90s, yes.
I mean, because we remember
before there was internet, right?
OK, alright, just making sure
I have family in the room here.
But I love that our generation
started to ask for more.
More balance, more recognition,
more sustainability, more consciousness
around how we show up
in the world, in society,
as well as on the planet.
And I think you referenced as well, Gen Z.
Gen Z asking for -- like Gen Z is bold.
Gen Z, shout out.
(Cheers)
I love it, I love it.
Maybe y'all will help me put
some stuff on TikTok later today.
So just catch me backstage, OK?
But that belonging component
is a force multiple with Gen Z.
It is "I'm going to show up
and be all who I am."
MDP: It's a requirement,
it's not an entitlement.
When I grew up, you know,
my parents raised me -- my brother and I
are first-generation college,
I'm first generation corporate America.
And we were taught
to be better, faster, smarter,
but to compete at average.
That never sat right with me.
But I was taught to fit in, not add in.
Gen Z is saying, here's where I add in,
and this is what we have to do
as corporations and organizations.
It's not about who fits into the culture,
it's what's missing in the culture
and who adds in the culture.
(Applause)
SD: That's an amazing point.
And I love that you talked
about the belonging
because it's less
of the quota of diversity, right?
It's more than just, I'm a data point
that potentially represents something.
MDP: Much broader than that.
It's much broader than that.
I mean, in talking about culture add,
and we've trained over 10,000
managers at Google
on how to interview for additive skills,
not just fitting in,
because that's a mindset shift
and change management
that we have to do on our side,
from a corporate America side,
to ensure that we're taking full advantage
of this incredible talent
that's in the world.
SD: And so, just as a closing,
what is your advice to other leaders
that are struggling to figure out
how do we create this new culture?
How do we still prioritize
what diversity looks like,
what belonging looks like,
and continue to even just measure
the progress as we go along?
MDP: My advice is to recognize
what we're talking about
are universal solutions
that are common to humanity.
But we have to recognize
that there are communities
within the universe
that are situated differently
and require different treatment
to take full advantage.
This is a basic right
and a basic privilege.
And if we could all, as leaders, stand
and take stock of that
and lift as we climb
and ensure we're bringing everybody along,
we will reach the culture
that we aspire to.
SD: That's incredible, yes, thank you.
(Applause)
Well, we see why
you are such an amazing boss.
MDP: Thank you.
SD: We get to witness it live,
this is incredible.
Melonie, thank you so much
for joining us here on the stage
today at TEDWomen.
Thank you for everyone here as well.
And thank you to the HBCU students
who are also in the room representing.
MDP: Thank you, thank you.
SD: Thanks everyone.
(Applause)